one huge entrepreneur in Brazil the  police came to his office at six o'clock  in the morning seven o'clock in the  morning his crime was in a in a WhatsApp  group closed group they were talking  about Lula and the possibilities of Lula  going back to Power and the guy one of  them said oh I'd rather live in a  dictatorship than that and the guy like  sent a like  alike and that's it like he liked it he  likes the message the message and the  police was at his place sick get out of  here and his and his private WhatsApp  group  wait wait wait a billionaire liked the  post I'd rather have a dictator not a  post what was it like it was a military  government yeah what's up relatives I'd  rather have a military government than  having listen Lula in office I was part  of the group I was part of I was in the  group and that's it